hello my name is Jose Lee a
undergraduate in triple is qinghai
University today I'm going to talk about
my recent work with said Hazard Banerjee
being sent to cover a DOT and an open
Gap talk graph searching with
predictions
first let's have a look at the problem
definition
start off at some root R looking for a
gold G as shy in a figure your red
vertices are explored and the blue ones
are on the boundary
at each time step T the agent chooses
the vertex on the boundary and move to
there paying the distance as the
movements cost
the objective is to minimize the total
movement cost when the agent reaches the
goal
because it is an online problem we
consider competitive analysis comparing
the cost of the algorithm to the optimal
cost incurred in hindsights which is
just capital D the distance between the
roots and the goal
however if I increase this problem has
very pessimistic guarantees in absence
of any further constraints consider a
complete binary tree with depth D and
the goal lies on one of the leaves
then the agent has to reach half of them
in expectation to find the goal
incurring a cost of Omega 2 to the D
so previous Works enforced topological
constraints on the graph for example
they consider cases like Grid or k-pass
from the roots
in our work however we consider the
graph searching problem in the advice
setting which is each node B gives a
prediction FV of its distance to the
goal
if all the predictions are correct then
the problem is very trivial we can just
walk downhill which is um starting from
the rules of distance D to the goal we
find its neighbor of distance B minus
one then D minus two and then finally we
can catch the roots in these steps which
is just the optimal but what if some of
the predictions are incorrect
we want to answer this question because
in real life black box but unreliable
predictions are very often so it's
important to know how to use these
unreliable advice
even the unreliable predictions our goal
is to find a robust algorithm which
finds the goal incurring a cost of D
plus some function of the prediction
Arrow basically if the arrow is very low
then our algorithm should also have very
low cost however if the prediction is
not so accurate they have a lot of
arrows then we can have more budgets
here we use Delta to denote the maximum
degree in the graph and e as a number of
vertices which give ground predictions
we can see this function of Arrow it has
a lower bound of Delta times the arrow
term
improve the lower bound is easy consider
the tree where the root has Delta this
joint Paths of less D leaving it and
each node gives now prediction as shown
in a figure
then by definition the only erroneous
nodes are those on the path from R to G
which are the just the originals so the
arrow is d
but since the prediction gives no
information the agent has to reach at
least half of the leaves to find the
goal so the cost is at least Omega Delta
times the arrow term here we finish the
proof
our main result is stated by this
theorem we give an algorithm GX and
prove that it almost achieves the best
performance this part will be the main
part of this talk
now we come to the exploration problem
here exploration problem is just a
problem we have discussed before we use
this name to distinguish with a simpler
version called planning problem which is
also discussed in our paper
for time's sake this talk will not cover
the planning problem parts
let's first get some intrusions about
the problem starting from the now
prediction cases
recall that now prediction is just as
shown in a figure the notes on the eyes
layer give prediction I plus d
then here is an observation if a is the
neighbor neighbor of the roots such that
gold lies in a sub G then only the nodes
in a sub gave ground predictions it's uh
it's just by definition C the orange
nodes in a figure
this fact gives us an idea if we balance
the exploration on both sides um
basically almost we explore the same
number of orange and red nodes then
because the orange nodes are erroneous
the total exploration can be bounded by
Arrow for the movement because we can
further use doubling technique to bound
it we will see it later
based on the ideas we can give this
simple algorithm for Simplicity we can
just imagine the chi is a binary tree
the algorithm is first we arbitrarily
choose one child of the root as a side
to explore then we do DFS on the current
side of the roots until the nodes
explored on the current side is at least
twice the nodes explored on the other
side then we turn to the other side due
to the DFS until the goal is reached
let's see how this algorithm works
basically it explores a sub tree for one
node then B sub tree for two nodes a sub
tree for four notes something like that
so we can see the red nodes explored is
always bounded by twice the orange nodes
explored
thus we can see the total acceleration
is bounded by all orange which is O
Arrow
furthermore by doubling technique which
is we enforce the number of explored
nodes to double each time it changes the
side which is insured by the algorithm
we have the movement cost is bounded by
o at the exploration
thus we get the proof
having shown the now prediction case we
then present our results in an important
special case called the noun B case
we consider the case when D is noun and
hope to generalize the ideas in our
prediction cases
the intuitions are very similar we try
to balance the load and we shall be
introduced later on each side of every
node thus we bound the acceleration by
the arrow
the movement cost is bounded by all
acceleration by the doubling technique
we first give several definitions
anchor a node use anchor is the ancestor
in a Level D plus Lu minus f u divided
by 2. see the left figure for
illustration the rather notes anchor is
the yellow one
here is an important claim a node U is
correctly predicted if and only if its
anchor is the least common ancestor of U
energy see the right figure
if the red node's prediction is correct
its anchor should be the yellow note
which is the least common ancestor of
the red one in the in the green one
note that here we only need D to
calculate use anchor and also note that
in our predictions all nodes have the
roots as their anchor by definition
based on the definition of anchor we
then Define load Sigma I to be the
number of nodes in a sub in the I sub
tree of U whose anchor is u for example
in this case Sigma 1 is equal to 2 which
is the number of the green nodes and the
sigma 2 equal to 4 and sigma is the sum
of all the sigma I which is 6.
now critical
for any node u and v let's a b use child
with the smallest load and B be used
child such that V is in B sub tree see
the figure
we denote the nodes with anchor U with
color red and green and all other nodes
in the bottom subtree with with orange
then we call you a critical node with
respect to V if
red is at least twice the green and red
is no smaller than Orange
here we give several examples the left
one is critical the top right one is not
critical because red is three and is
less than twice the number of green
the bottom right one is not critical
because red is smaller than the orange
we can State our algorithm now at any
time step t y o g is not reached yet do
DFS for one step
let's U be vt's angular If U is critical
with respect to VT let's a b use child
with the smallest load and then change
to a sub tree to do to do DFS
here we have to note that although T
does not appear explicitly in the
algorithm we needed to compute the
anchors and nodes
for this now B setting we prove that
given D this algorithm finds the goal
incurring a cost of D plus o Delta times
the error term
to prove the theorem first we need to
introduce the concepts of extra
exploration
extra exploration is a sub sheets which
do not contain G
refers or partition it into extra
exploration rooted on different nodes on
the parts from R to G
in our proof we try to bound the extra
acceleration by the arrow terms and then
because the total exploration is at most
D larger than it
the total exploration can also be
bounded
the military now prediction cases we
also have key observations
for any node U on the path from R to G
let a be a sub tree that contains G
then the cross nodes which are the nodes
whose anchor is u in Upper sub tree and
other nodes whose anchor is not you
they must give wrong predictions
the proof is just straightforward by the
definition of anchor
also we State the invariance
basically our algorithm in brief is a
2dfs until critical and then change the
side this maintains the following
environments for NAU underpass from R to
G suppose G lies on lies in the upper
sub tree
let screen notes be the ones in the
upper sub tree whose anchor is you
in a lower subtree let's read notes be
the ones who then create issue and the
orange one be the rest
then at least one of the following three
statements is true red is smaller than
twice the green where the oil is smaller
than orange or the third one here the
third one is the special case and the
four intrusions we just ignore it in the
following proof
the analysis can be derived by the
observations and the invariance
first from our writing variants we have
either the red is smaller than twice the
green or red is smaller than Orange
so the extra exploration rooted on U it
can be it is a red plus orange and it
can be bounded by all green plus Orange
however by the observations green and
orange nodes are all wrongly predicted
moreover the green nodes and the orange
nodes for difference node U they are
destroyed so the sum of green plus
orange for different U it is bounded by
o Arrow hence we we bound the
exploration by the arrow
we have bounded the extra exploration
then to bound the movement cost we
partition all the edge transversals into
several parts and then we use doubling
technique to analyze the Callback cost
caused by each node in the graph for
time's sake we skip this part in the in
this talk for more details we invite you
to read our paper
given the algorithm for the 90 case we
will now consider the unknown the case
which is the exploration problem
recall our main theorem 3x algorithms
solves the problem incurring a cost o b
plus Delta times the error term
here we give a sketch of our 3x
algorithm
the main ideas are each time we explore
increasing portions of the tree if we
can find a node whose prediction must be
correct running algorithm 1 rooted at
this node it solves the problem
so the problem becomes to find a correct
predictor basically if most observed
nodes they are correct we Define a tree
separator and prove that its prediction
can be found out otherwise most observed
nodes they are incorrect then the error
is very large so we have budget to
explore further
note that here we can sample to get the
correct predictor however randomizing
leads to extra log terms
now we Define a tree separator given GT
a tree separator is a node v such that
it has two neighbors a and a b and both
of A and B sub G they have the size
larger than T divided by 2 Delta
Q claims are made first this tree
separator exists and second we can know
its correct prediction
first we prove its existence
let V be the centroid of the tree which
is deleting V breaks T into a forward
containing sub trees of size at most T
divided by 2.
That's A and B be the two neighbors with
largest sub trees
then by pigeonhole serum we can have
that they are just the neighbors we are
looking for and a b is just the tree
separator
then we Define the concepts of both
these votes for C is FV minus the
distance between c and b in the dominant
votes in a sub tree is the vote which
more than half of the nodes in a sub
tree holds
here we should note that if these
prediction is correct and the g does not
lie in a sub tree this vote is just the
distance from C to G
the proof of this observation is
straightforward by definition
now we can see the proof we State the
complete observation here
for any correct node U if GE lies in
different sub trees with you this volts
is just distance from CG otherwise the
volts the vote is smaller
when the tree explored is large enough
at most half of the nodes in a b sub G
they tell the lie so either either A and
B sub G they do not have dominant votes
all the dominant votes tell the truth
if G is not in a sub tree then by the
observation the vote is just the
distance otherwise the dominant votes
does not exist or is smaller than a
distance
since G can lying at most one of the the
two sub trees takes the maximum of the
two dominant votes we can get the
distance from C to G
finally we conclude our results and give
some open problems
we have some of the graph searching with
predictions problem in three cases but
there are still things to discuss
first how does things come if the advice
goes in Greater information instead
one thing to note is that we take the
setting of The adversible Arrow
considering the number of Errors made in
total
the other stronger Arrow setting is the
stochastic one which assumes that each
prediction is drawn by a probability
with States in our paper that in
adversible setting greater information
is not enough
however if we consider greater
information in stochistic error setting
it is another branch of work called
noisy binary search
also we only discussed or unweighted
trees in our work we have to note that
in our setting any algorithm cannot
solve the problem in weighted trees with
boundary cost even when we consider the
L1 Arrow instead of the l01
we hope our workings by Future Works and
we list some of the probable open
problems here
the first and most natural open
direction is to generalize the results
to General graphs
we only step a little Beyond trees in
planning problems and more results are
left to the Future
also reducing the space complexity to
use them on very large implicitly
defined graphs it can be interesting
then we can use the results in cases
such as large sleeping problems or RL
problems something like that
and finally multiple agent settings and
other broader forms of advice are also
in triggering directions
thanks for listening to our presentation
and we invite you to take a look at our
paper for more details